bonjour s'est tenu le dernier sommet
franco allemand avec emmanuel macron et
angela merkel puisque cette dernière à
mettre fin à ses activités politiques
quel bilan faites vous de l'action de la
chancelière je pense que elle a d'abord
sur un plan économique très bien
poursuivie et profiter de la décision
majeure prise par son prédécesseur le
socialiste au choix d'heure 2-2 d'avoir
fait toutes ces réformes qui ont permis
à la fois d'augmenter la tva pour faire
une sorte de dévaluation discrète et
de réduire les allocations chômage etc
pour mettre du liant dans l'économie
allemande et améliorer l'efficacité de
cette économie et la productivité de
cette économie qui ont permis à
l'allemagne de s'imposer dans le cadre
d'un grand marché à la fois européen et
mondial
et avec cette monnaie est l'euro marque
elle n'a absolument rien apporté de neuf
elle a simplement profité de cette
décision qui avait coûté le pouvoir à
schoder maintenant sur tout le reste
je pense qu'elle à l art à une commande
une influence délétère sur sur la sur
l'allemagne et sur le rock c'est à dire
qu'elle à gauchy la démocratie
chrétienne elle à gauchy la démocratie
chrétienne l'a amené d'ailleurs sur les
plates bandes des verts d'ailleurs y
vont ils vont sans doute leur
transmettre le pouvoir selon la vieille
règle que les électeurs préfèrent
l'original à la copie
car pense d'avoir copié les verts sur le
plan de l'immigration sur le plan 2d des
moeurs mariages homosexuels etc
sur le plan des fameuses valeurs de
l'état de droit et c'est enfin il n'y a
plus de différence aujourd'hui entre les
chrétiens-démocrates et la gauche à la
fois social démocrate et verte
d'abord je note que c'est une expression
seulement française et des allemands
sourit poliment devant cette cette
approche romantique des français en fait
qu'est ce que c'est au départ le couple
franco-allemand c'est la volonté du
général de gaulle d'arrimer la
république fédérale d'allemagne à
l'époque coupé en deux avec séparer de
la république de la rda qui était
soumise à eau à l'est et au communisme
de la rime est donc cette rfa à la
france pour permettre
si vous devez pour que la puissance
économique de la rfa renforce la main
géostratégique de l'allemagne de gaulle
avec son art de la forme un pardon
excusez moi de la france de gaulle avec
son art de la formule disait à
perrefitte la france sera le jockey et
l'allemagne sera le cheval
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui la
réunification allemande de 90 à a mis un
premier clou sur le cercueil de cette
stratégie est la 2 le deuxième c'est
évidemment la réussite il hégémonie
économique allemande dans le cadre du
grand marché en plus dans une rampe à 6
marché commun de gaulle ce qui ressemble
sur graphiquement halal empire de
charlemagne et même à l'empiré de
napoléon
la france est à l'aise dans une europe à
27 on retrouve plutôt les fondamentaux
de lempire du saint-empire romain
germanique ou l'allemagne retrouve ses
repères donc françois mitterrand a cru
que en faisant l'euro et en leur prenant
le deutsch mark qu'il qualifiait de la
bombe atomique et des allemands il
allait
river le clou aux allemands que nenni en
fait la zone euro n'a permis que de
renforcer l'hégémonie industrielle
allemande au sein de l'europe
donc vous voyez tout cela échoue et les
présidents français désormais on
essayait successivement sarkozy chirac
sarkozy hollande de desserrer l'étau des
contraintes budgétaires prévues par
maastricht on s'en souvient et à chaque
fois ils ont échoué et devaient
piteusement se soumettre à l'allemagne
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron à changer de
registre
il veut absolument convertir l'allemagne
à son concept d'autonomie de
souveraineté de défense européenne
il ne veut pas comprendre pourtant les
dirigeants allemands lui répète sur tous
les tons que pour l'allemagne
la défense européenne ça s'appelle
l'otan et que les allemands depuis 45
préféreront toujours se soumettre à
l'hégémonie militaire et stratégique
américaine plutôt qu'à ça son homologue
française qui est à la fois plus proche
est moins puissante et ça finalement
c'est le français qui se soumet à
l'amérique pour ne pas pour ne pas
abandonner la main de l'allemagne brille
et ccc c'est le monde à l'envers tout
simplement que la france devrait
admettre et devrait comprendre et
devrait renoncer à son complexe
d'infériorité par rapport à l'allemagne
ce n'est pas la puissance économique
allemande qui protège la france c'est
plutôt là des rares atouts français qui
est son armée et sa puissance militaire
et son complexe militaro-industriel
qu'il nous faudrait au contraire
renforcer sans chercher sans fin le
l'alliance avec avec l'allemagne qui qui
ne pense qu'à nous piquer nos éventuels
secrets de fabrication il nous faut
assumer nos spécificités
c'est à dire une politique mondiale que
nous destine notre espace maritime qui
est le deuxième du monde et notre
puissance militaro industriel qu il
faut au contraire renforcé nous devrions
multiplier les alliances nous avons
d'autres alliés en europe sur des tas de
sujets l'italie l'espagne le les pays de
l'est
cc on devrait plutôt chercher des
coalitions au sein de l'union européenne
plutôt que de tout sacrifier à une à une
amitié et à une symbiose
franco-allemande qui n'est plus que le
reflet de notre affaiblissement de notre
suggestion